hast du mal bei uns gespielt jetzt
sechste sehr schön die das aber wohl gar
nicht erst wird ich glaube schon
games und willkommen zu meiner ja ich
glaube meine allerersten folge mettwurst
heute mit dem gsm beten wir spielen in
rüthnick die map für alle die das nicht
kennt ich schieb mal kurz mein orchester
in das sehen kann wie ok jetzt baute mir
natürlich quatsch spaß ich habe gelabert
tut mir leid jetzt ok komm runter
beruhigte ich ja dann sehr wichtig so
leute wie ich bin jetzt als erste mal
auf ohr produzieren so im alltag
normalerweise mache ich nie sondern wenn
ihr mal irgendwie urlaub fahren oder so
und da auch dann nicht besonders gut
aber jetzt vor produzieren
und da hinten geht's rüber da waren auch
direkt mal die connection ja dort ist
man da alle erste webos runde also
schreibt bitte alle die kommentare
hashtags du blöder knapp 80 logisch oder
oder oder
das ist eine richtige warum muten der da
jetzt eine treppe also ich wollte euch
dazu ich hoffe dass er drüber sondern
haben übrigens zwei schwerter und eine
schöne geste wo ich danke dir danke
leute wie gesagt verzeih mir mal dass
ich jetzt nicht etwas scilla bin ich
will es einfach mal ausprobieren
wir zocken wir die muppets mit den
köpfen von zahllosen baby 1991 einigen
baby nicht okay wir hatten auch schon
einen kommentar nach ist es mir denn ich
werde meine platte liegen in der kiste
hatte ich packe meine edelmetall
register rein und da oben immer weiter
sozusagen als kanonenfutter auch schön
die leute hier gemacht sehr gut ich
schaue persönlich nicht so viel komme
überhaupt kein komme sei also direkt ist
ist nicht so meins machte schockvideos
aber ich finde es nicht so spannend und
falls ihr natürlich mal wollt dass ich
war irgendwie in seinem video meine
lieblings youtuber vorstelle dann könnt
ihr das gerne meinen die komplette
ausschreibung
google wird einzig auf platz 15 kommt
einfach logo aber ich habe die ersten
fünf plätze 15 einfach deinen eigenen
kanal
ja genau herzlich willkommen zu einem
egoistischen film video formate gehabt
für mich da kannst du ja co aber ich
kann dich nicht hätten
ich kann ich denn ich konnte nie früher
konnte man noch mit feuerzeugen schlagen
jetzt nichtbeachtung bild ist formal
dankeschön ich danke bis heute oben da
kannst du direkt zu droppen
dies entstand hier hoch ist der bruder
oder nach dem restaurant sonst droht
also ich weiß es nicht
ja ich will ich will ich will ich werde
ich denke ich denke aber es hängt ja
hallo leute hallo hallo gedrängt dies
offen nichts half nichts oh mein gott
killy einfach mal alle bitte ich kenne
ja locker easy ok ich darum ist noch
einer hinterher und das war alter gar
nicht eingebaut wenn uns jetzt natürlich
spiel ist aus der kommt wartet schützt
das bett erst noch kommt ja aber egal
dann beschützt das bett dann vergisst
dass t unserer einigung mit dessen
miniaturen ja jetzt noch ab und wir
werden halt das nicht da unten ist ein
neuer gestorben was machen wir jetzt
machen wir jetzt noch mal der runde tor
ist ja oder mama noch so eine kleine und
eine kleine runde und dann sehen uns
gleich wieder da sind wir wieder meine
sehr verehrten entfernt
hallo ladies und etschenberg wildes
hupen ladies in action gehen wenn das
muss man das muss man unterstützen wollt
dann schritten die kommentare hashtag
ladies und ein action band nachdem er
jetzt und genauso wie er denkt dass man
schreibt also es ist klar dass mit der
coolsten rechtschreibung gewinnen eine
kaffeetasse theologisch steht alter geil
das angebot meine kaffeetasse gewinnt
also gar nicht gerade bestellt machen
ok also sonst verkauft hat einen super
die ich brauche ich heute bin ich nicht
und ich mach wieder den baumeister da
fällt kaum auf dass ich keine basecap
hallo war sie hat es gesagt es geht über
der skelett bekomme selbst gelernt
also ich weiß noch dass da das irgendwie
französisch für gummi ist oder so glaube
ich doch oder
ich glaube übersetzt kommen sicherlich
auch gummi sexpuppe und hatte dann das
ist nicht wirklich viel anfühlt ja gut
weiß ich jetzt nicht aber doch noch
leute ich würde schon sagen gummi gummi
sex also addierte aus bethen und
richtung mekka beten junge leute auf dem
fall keine hält komme ist doch ein mit
love peace genauer komme ist kaum etwas
geändert oder messing
we make love work hochwasser das gerät
ich bin da drunter gesprochen habe im
fallen quasi noch den block passiert
wenn darauf gelandet gesprungen es war
das für die aktion als erst recht durch
ein unwetter hat in jeansjacke hat den
sprung nicht geschafft
du bist du einen renn dialekt ist auch
klar dass die sache so machbar dass das
lag vielleicht daran dass ich einfach
darüber stand 123 44 sind ich einfach
nur noch zehn prozent meiner motorischen
logischen fähigkeiten wie die logischen
fähigkeiten abnehmen und der typ hat
mich auch gern unter leuten in meinem
team
gratuliere ok ich glaube ich schon jetzt
aber eine spitzhacke hast du irgendwie
logisch das material da unten
neuenstein dieser bastard ende zu
entdecken was teile ich meine diese
hastet er meinte dieser dieser
klassenkamerad ich hab so schnell
ausgesprochen
ja klassen kramer tat was manchmal
glauben wir die leute nicht was jetzt
hier nicht finden und ein roter ranzen
raten wollt oder bin ich damals gold
da ist das golf kombi kosten spitzhacke
in gold gold gold
ich hole mir die arbeit die hier und ein
schwert und kommentaren getreide kostete
kister ein silberner die kisten sind
auch mal einfach mal hier würde ich
sagen
kleine kiste hin da kann man ganz auf
mein team hat eine kantate ich ich
könnte einfach über ist mit einer
spitzhacke und wartete auf mich wartet
auf mich ich habe doch nichts zu
verlieren
leider muss ich für mich ablenken wir
müssen einfach zusammen machen dann
machen wir jetzt mal über gestört weil
hier die dinge können ich hab einfach
kaum auf den hunger reinzulaufen auf
aktuell über die tracks das hat nichts
mit diesen ziemlich gut gekühlt naja
egal kann man probieren rushhour jackie
chan
warum bist du
junge was macht ihr da der bisher ist
heute tine wittler und videos hallo und
sind was ist denn los mit der junge war
ja schon gespannt ich liebe es die wand
anzuschauen darum geht es wenn du es nie
wirklich sein
was macht ihr da steht immer noch da
junge wetten der ist gehört in die küche
gegangen auf die bratkartoffeln europas
bleibt dabei einfach in game den kenne
ich noch so jemanden der das einfach mal
ja die aber ich mache es nicht in der
aufnahme ich mache nur versuchen wir
gerne weil bratkartoffeln toll sind
viele kartoffeln wie gesagt
bratkartoffeln mit guitar von rational
so ein bisschen ein hohes beste oder
bisschen rahmen bauen
euro bis jetzt zeigt sich immer wieder
was sich ein händler game sulander geld
weil wir gerne ändern games spielen sehr
gut
nein an wetters nicht so toll findet
dass sich die runden teilweise so ultras
in die länge ziehen
also wir könnten es eigentlich beenden
ja dann lasst es uns beenden
das werde ich eine supertolle lände
supertoll würdig zu feiern ihr du machst
denn der inzwischen so viel scheiße ich
weiß es nicht wir sind irgendwie hier in
angeschlossen
ok auffällig für mich irgendwie hab ich
gefühl dass wir mit nicht ganz geistig
fähigen leuten zusammen sind in der lage
um die uhrzeit ist keiner mehr da ist
ich will aber jetzt einfach mal durch
waschen das kann nicht so schwer sein
was macht jojo zweck da kann man sich
davon da oben rein bauen geht das nie so
weit ich weiß im letzten update der map
ging halt nicht wenn überhaupt ein
update wird geld updated mit update ist
der neue begriff von wer ihm geht
updated weiß schon jetzt was ihm
passiert wir brauchen wir sie
das war natürlich gut oder es wird eine
lange runde aber okay das kann schnell
ich finds richtig verpackt das doch
jetzt klar ich meine das ist kein
problem da keine sowieso mit obs
aufnehmen ist alles entspannt wenn das
jetzt klappen mit dem ton weil wir das
so machen mussten
ihr habt ihr kind bekommt bei dem also
wenn ich anderen leuten aufnehmen sind
ihren obs unfassbar leise also schreibt
mir bitte mal die kommentare was ich da
machen kann auf jeden fall aber bitte
nur wenn ihr selbst obs habt und wisst
was das problem ist wie man es lösen
kann dann schreibt man das in die
kommentare
dann bin ich euch sehr dankbar die
tollsten menschen auf der welt
nein damit belohnt sich einfach ganz
ehrlich dieser typ ist einfach der
sinnloseste typ aller zeiten ich glaube
er steht da ist er belohne schlechthin
ich stehe da 15 15 minuten und guckt die
wand an gigi darunter geschlossen die
ganze zeit ja wie willst du etwas
überlegen also darum anschließend von
der seite das ist das ende wir müssen
uns von ganz oben
du musst jetzt ein richtig wohnen weg
bauen ja um dich dann so rüber zu bauen
ein steinschlag streichen okay das war
kein schritt so weit okay
neuenfels der invite hdz pando das muss
schneller gehen wir sind hier im bett
bleibt sind blöcke junge zeit zum glück
ich zeit sind blöcke hashtag zeitblöcke
ist einfach so viele coole sprüche raus
das war unfassbar acht der charta vorne
hoch soll der kauf einfach leiterin baue
ich mir zu mir
zehn stunden später herr ist mit dir
also ungefähr wie hast du's gespielt ich
bin logo zins um 26 grad so heftig
alter.de das aber wohl doch es wird ich
glaube schon
wer ihm lass es einfach nordkorea jiji
das viel kraft einfach gerade nicht okay
was los schreiben einfach mal unser bett
wurde zerstört
wahrscheinlich war scheine ich weiß
nicht so wie mein kollektion ist offen
jetzt können wir machen uns auf ein
schönes leben noch bis uns bisschen
holen und wir dann verrieten blut der ts
wurde die dort gesagt dass ich mir das
war der könig der ts wurde die lust er
ist kein mitteilte test der das
datenvolumen erreicht was du erreichen
kannst
zeox pvp wie baut ihr euer bett ein gar
nichts rx pvp weil hier keiner plan hat
und einkommen hallo hallo eingebaut
haben ich werfe der letzte war einfach
der letzte der dennoch wohnt ihr wollt
mich haben ihr wollt mich haben drei
leute und lasst den daumen nach oben da
wenn euch das video gefallen hat wie
gesagt keine ahnung irgendwie diese
zweite map token überhaupt nicht gut das
haben wir verpackt kam optieren denkmal
die runde war mit ddos dann auch noch
relativ lustig so ich werde euch dann
irgendwie zusammen schneiden das hier
und jetzt sich 20 minuten dauert so wie
sie gerade ist und dann sehen was beim
nächsten video wieder
falls sie mehr wert als gold und ich
besser werden soll schreibt in die
kommentare könnt gerne alles die
kommentare schon was ihr wollt wie
gesagt seht es mir nach dass ich nicht
so gut bin und dass ich wieder bei
logitech habe der eine beschreibung ist
bis dann